oscope
31390 enregistré le 15 mai à 15h45
diffusé le 15 mai à 20h35 séquence 1
2e
valer giscardestin je ne vous ai jamais
rencontré nous avons échangé nos
premiers mots il y a quelques minutes en
entrant dans ce studio vous avez
souhaité vous entretenir avec moi
je vous ai demandé vous avez accepté de
respecter la règle de mes conversations
radiophoniques cette règle c'estes
règles sont très simples je ne vois
jamais les personnes que j'accueille
avant l'émission elles ne sont pas du
tout au courant des questions que je
peux leur poser les choses se passent
ainsi comme peuvent en témoigner marcher
André mer criine sanginetti mesance et
je pourrais en citer beaucoup
d'autres nous n'allons pas parler de
politique ce que je veux c'est aller à
la rencontre de l'homme que vous êtes il
y a eu après le débat télévisé qui vous
a opposé à François
mitteran un sondage c'est la mode des
sondage qui fait apparaître quelques
réflexions et je les ai noté ces
réflexions vous êtes brillant vous êtes
sympathique convaincant dynamique
sincère mais vous êtes moins à l'aise
que François mitteran vous êtes moins
loyal moins habile et puis ce qui ce qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui vous êtes moins
humain moins humain voilà la question
pourquoi moins humain JEE la question
oui je crois que c'est une question
d'âge ce qu'on appelle humumain
lorsqu'on porte un jugement sur
quelqu'un c'est le fait qu'il est connu
enduré traversé un certain nombre de
circonstances quand quelqu'un est jeune
on ne dit pas que c'est quelqu'un
d'humain on dit que c'est quelqu'un de
sympathique et puis c'est ensuite en
effet plus tard dans l'existence que
l'on vous donne cette étiquette d'humain
je dirais que être moins à l'aise et
être sympathique c'est le signe d'une
certaine jeunesse c'est plus tard que on
peut mériter le qualificatif d'humain
vous estimez que vous êtes transformé au
cours de cette campagne vous avez parlé
de vous une fois mais vous parliez de
vous au passé et ce qui nous intéresse
ce qui intér intéresse le téléspectateur
le français c'est l'homme d'aujourd'hui
l'homme que vous êtes que vous êtes
peut-être devenu non je ne suis pas
transformé au cours de cette campagne
personne ne se transforme en en quelque
s fais dans des concessions parfois ça
c'est autre chose ça ne serait pas se
transformer non je ne me suis pas
transformé parce que ce que j'ai essayé
d'être dans cette campagne que je suis
dans cette campagne c'est ce que je suis
mais l'opinion publique avait de moi une
idée différente il était naturel qu'elle
est une idée différente parce qu'elle
l'avait au travers de ma fonction elle
me connaissait comme ministre de
l'économie et des finances et donc elle
me jugeait comme elle estime juger un
ministre de l'économie et des finances
mais d'autres personnes par exemple mes
amis ou mes électeur en Verne Savit très
bien que ce que je suis était différent
donc je nai pas changé au cours de cette
campagne mais ce qui est différent
peut-être c'est que ma communication
avec l'opinion française elle a changé
vous êtes polytechnicien vous êtes éarc
certains disent que vous êtes un
ordinateur vous avez le goût des
chiffres au début de la campagne vous
étiez Valérie giscardestin ensuite vous
étiez Giscard vous êtes ensuite Valérie
on pourrait penser que si la campagne
durait encore vous iriez tutoyer la
France et je me demande si vous êtes
fait pour cette familiarité mais ce que
j'ai observé au cours de cette campagne
c'est deux mouvements c'est d'une part
un mouvement que j'ai fait en direction
de l'opinion publique pour exposer un
certain nombre de problèmes pour établir
un certain contact qui s'est établi et
puis il y a eu un mouvement qui a été
fait en sens contraire par l'opinion
publique et qui de son côté a apporté
quelque chose dans cette campagne
apporté quelque chose à ma rencontre je
l'ai dit j'étais très frappé et touché
par exemple lorsque je sors des salles
de réunion par tous ceux qui vous disent
bonne chance c'est un mot qu'on adresse
à quelqu'un vis-à-vis de qui on établit
un lien la bonne chance ce n'est pas un
mot du langage politique c'est un mot du
langage personnel donc je je crois que
ce contact très direct entre l'opinion
publique et le candidat à la présidence
de la République c'est fondamental il
n'est pas douteux que vous avez de
l'ambition que vous avez le goût de la
puissance que vous avez le goût du
pouvoir et on peut se poser la question
pourquoi un homme veut-être président de
la République car on le sait être
président de la République c'est entrer
dans le monde de la solitude dans un
désert c'est être au-dessus de tout le
monde et n'avoir surtout personne
audessus de soi vous avez raison je ne
crois par je il faut faire attention à
ce mot d'ambition c'est un mot qui est
péjoratif il vous va bien ambition je ne
crois pas bon j'ai surprendre parce que
quelqu'un qui est là qui est candidat à
la présidence de la République qui le
dit à ses compatriotes naturellement il
exerce une ambition seulement je je
pense au mot ambition au sens habituel
le jeune homme ambitieux je ne suis plus
ambitieux dans ce sens-là je l'ai été et
je l'été notamment lorsque j'étais jeune
ministre parce que j'étais fier de
l'aide j'étais conscient de l'autorité
que ça vous donnait du pouvoir que ça
vous donnait
et puis quand j'ai quitté le
gouvernement c'està-d en 1966 j'ai été
éloigné du gouvernement pendant 3 ans et
à ce moment-là j'ai mesuré les limite en
réalité de l'ambition et lorsque je suis
revenu au ministère de l'économie et des
finances mon mon intention ça n'était
plus l'ambition ce n'était pas la
satisfaction d'être ministre c'était de
mieux faire ce que j'avais fait la
première fois que j'estimais ne pas
avoir fait aussi bien ou assez loin que
j'aurais dû le faire à l'époque et je
dirais qu'à l'heure actuelle qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé le président Pompidou de
devait rester président de la République
jusqu'en 1976 donc il n'y avait pas
d'échéance pour l'ambition
présidentielle pour personne c'est un
événement qui a été soudain qui a été
frappant et il se trouve que j'étais
parmi ceux qui devaient se se poser la
question mais je suis conscient comme
vous le dites du poids de la chose non
pas conscient parce que j'ai peur d'en
être écrasé j'ai toujours considéré dans
l'existence que lorsqu'on veut faire
quelque chose quoi que ce soit il faut
vouloir la chose et accepter les
inconvénients de la chose on ne peut pas
vouloir être président de la République
et s'effrayer ou se dérober au poids de
la fonction poids qui est effectivement
écrasant mais ce qui m'intéresse dans
cette candidature ça n'est pas le fait
d'être nommé président de la République
c'est le fait d'avoir la chance de faire
quelque chose comme président de la
République et si je peux vous en faire
la confidence lorsque le soir je rentre
de ces réunions tard et qu'on pense
qu'on a un moment de tranquillité je me
dis qu'est-ce que je penserai dans
quelques année si j'étais élu président
de la République qu'est-ce que j'aurais
fait est-ce que j'aurais le sentiment
véritablement d'avoir accompli quelque
chose alors c'est ça si vous voulez mon
ambition dimanche c'est une élection
capitale mais si c'était une exécution
capitale si vous perdiez comment
réagiriez-vous d'ailleurs vous êtes dans
la position de l'homme qui veut gagner
qui a gagné nous sommes deux dans de
dans la position d'hommes qui voulont
normalement gagner on le veut vraiment
on le veut vraiment oui on le veut
vraiment je considère vous avez dit
c'est un choix grave pour moi c'est un
choix grave pour la France c'est un
choix grave pour moi dans une certaine
mesure mais c'est un choix grave pour la
France et ça me ferait profondément de
l'angoisse et de la peine de voir la
France se tromper c'est en ce sensl que
c'est un choix grave alors je ne
raisonne pas en terme de victoire et de
défaite et je vous dirais je n'aime pas
ce vocabulaire il ne s'agit pas
d'écraser l'adversaire ou d'être écrasé
par lui il n'y aura personne de
décapiter c'est un choix il faut
imaginer que la France est sur une route
qui a une bifurcation qu'elle peut
prendre l'une ou l'autre de deux voix et
si elle choisit l'autre voix si c'est
l'autre voie qu'elle choisit et bien la
France aura choisie démocratiquement et
pour moi je suis quelqu'un qui suit de
tempérament et de nature démocratique
lorsque je dis que je suis libéral c'est
ça que je veux dire je respecte le choix
des autres je vais tout faire pour que
la France fasse le bon choix tout faire
j'ai fait cette campagne je vous parle
aujourd'hui je parlerai encore vendredi
pour que la France fasse le bon choix
mais si elle en fait un autre je
respecterai son choix vous avez de
l'estime pour votre adversaire je
considère que c'est un homme très
capable très capable et qui mène une
campagne qui est une campagne de
candidat la de la République j'estime
j'ai suivi comme peut-être comme vous
d'ailleurs des campagnes dans d'autres
grands pays et bien cette campagne faite
par mon adversaire c'est une campagne
normale de
qualité d'un candidat à la présidence de
la République il y a beaucoup
d'adjectifs pour vous désigner en dit
avisé réfléchi prudent acieux d'ailleurs
prudent ieux ça ne me pas ça oui il vous
manque peut-être d'être un peu
maladroit on dit ça moyennant quoi
l'autre jour dans une émission de
télévision j'ai fait trois petites
erreurs de langage mais je pas fait mon
émission en général je fais toujours une
fois simplement et on m'a dit ah vous
voyez vous avez fait trois erreurs de
langage alors il faut à la fois être
maladroit une palêtre si je comprends
bien non si vous croyez que je suis à
droit c'est pour une raison simple je
suis quelqu'un qui fait attention aux
choses et aux gens parce que je
considère que les choses et les êtres
c'est fragile et qu'il faut toujours
faire très attention il faut jamais être
brutal faut jamais être brusque il faut
jamais trancher dans le vif comme comme
on le dit il faut au contraire faire
très attention alors quand vous êtes
attention vous vous être ce que l'on
appelle à droit parce que en effet vous
évitez le les décisions soudaines ou
brusques ou les erreurs ou les choses
qui qui blaisse les êtres dans mon
ministère par exemple au milieu de mes
collaborateurs avec lesquel j'ai
travaillé pendant de longues années bien
j'ai toujours évité qu'il y ait des
tensions des antagonismes et lorsque je
sentais qu'il en existait avant la fin
de la journée même j'essayais qu'elle
disparaisse avez-vous changé de ton en
vous disant je serai président de la
République il faut que je sois un autre
homme et changez-vous de ton en ce
moment j'ai pas changéous non j'ai pas
changé de ton j'ai pas changé de ton si
vous voulez on prend effectivement
conscience de quelque chose c'est
d'ailleurs très surprenant puisque être
candidat à la présidence de la
République ça n'est évidemment pas être
président de la République les 12 que
nous étions voici 15 jours n'étions pas
président de la République seulement
comme vous êtes amené à à penser à la
dimension du problème et comme lorsque
vous parlez aux autres les autres vous
regardent eux en se disant c'est
peut-être un président de la République
alors vous prenez conscience de quelque
chose qui dans une certaine mesure vous
change certains coup vous ont fait mal
or nous n'avons jamais vu une trace
évidente sur votre visage de ces gooups
reçus êtes-vous insensible d'abord c'est
peut-être parce que vous n'z pas bien
regardé j'ai regardé et ensuite si vous
connaissez la nature humaine je pense
qu' vous étiez fier à ce moment-là mais
vous n'étiez pas touché un homme comme
vous qui qui la connaît qui j'essaie de
conna qui l'étudier n'est-ce pas ceux
qui en effet ne montrent pas certaines
choses ce ne sont pas les gens
insensibles ce sont les gens très
sensibles parce que si les gens très
sensi sensible laisse apparaître soit la
blessure soit le sentiment ils font
apparaître beaucoup de blessure ou
beaucoup de sentiments je quelqu'un dont
les réactions sont très fortes et dans
le la sensibilité est très forte et
c'est pourquoi en effet devant certaines
blessures qui existent je suis amené à
ne pas les laisser apparaître quelqu'un
de secret aussi parce que le Giscard
d'avant giscar on ne le connaît pas non
je suis pas quelqu'un de secret c'est
quelqu'un de réservé non d'abord je
respecte la loi du secret chose
fondamentale et pour un homme d'État
fondamental je l'ai dit à propos par
exemple du général de Gaulle j'ai été
comme comme ministre le familier du
général de Gaulle puisque j'avais avec
lui une conversation par semaine bon
vous avez vu le nombre de mémoire de
citations qui ont été écrites à propos
du général de gaaule comme je
considérais que c'était des
conversations en tête à-tête avec le
chef de l'État je n'ai jamais utiliser
une seule de ces conversations de ces
citations vous les utiliserez peut-être
un jour enfin le jour où ça ne sera plus
utile ou utilisable je veux dire si un
jour je dois écrire ce qui s'est passé à
un certain moment peut-être le ferai-je
mais certainement pas dans le combat ou
dans la lutte politique et je crois
qu'un homme d'État a le devoir de
respecter le la loi du secret il y a
dans votre période une suite anecdotique
de situation il y a eu l'homme au
poulovert il y a eu l'homme qui prenait
le métro il y a eu l'homme qui joue au
football à chavalière il y a eu
l'accordéoniste et encore tout récemment
vous étiez h matage de Rubby qui opposé
B Narbon et je crois savoir que vous
êtes beaucoup plus
passionné ou vous êtes plus de de
football que de rugby alors je me
demande si vous êtes battu si vous irez
à la finale de la coupe de de football
bien sûr si vous voulez tout ceci sont
des anecdotes mais dans ces anecdotes ou
mais elle témoigne d'un personnage elle
témoigne d'un personnage parce qu'on les
interprète je prends le cadre de mon
match de football l'année dernière à
chamalière on a dit que ça avait été un
montage ou quelque chose d'organisé on
pouvait s renseigner les commerçants de
la ville une organisation de commerçants
avait eu l'idée à l'occasion de la Fête
municipale de chamalier au début juin de
jeter un défi au Conseil municipal et
mes adjints m'avaient dit que nous
relevons le défi bien sûr nous allons
relever le défi et faire ce match donc
c'était quelque chose de local et de
spontané pas du tout d'apprêé mais ce
qui est vrai c'est que je me suis
toujours efforcé et si je suis élu
président de la République je
continuerai à m'efforcer de faire que
les hommes d'État en France apparaissent
comme des êtres plus simples nous avons
derrière nous une tradition de
convention de protocole tout à fait
excessive et qui n'est pas moderne car
vous savez très bien que dans les autres
grands pays ça n'est pas comme ça le
fait pour un président des États-Unis
d'apparaître en pouau vert naurait
intéressé ou frapper personne il n'y a
pas de ridicule non seulement il n'y a
pas de ridicule mais l'idée que
finalement ce sont des hommes comme les
autres qui exercent seulement des
fonctions plus importantes qui leur sont
confié pour une certaine durée mais que
ce sont des hommes comme les autres ceci
est accepté et jugé normal je souhaite
qu'en France et d'ailleurs j'ai l'idée
d'initiative à prendre à cet égard que
le Président de la République soit
considéré comme quelqu'un d'important
naturellement de respectable mais
quelqu'un qui commître comme homme en
réalité comme les autres vous êtes
raisonnable valergusquardestin mais
êtes-vous capable de jeter une
passerelle entre la raison et les
passions je suis beaucoup plus passionné
que raisonnable puisque vous me posez la
question raisonnablement passionné non
je suis beaucoup plus passionné que
raisonnable par nature mais lorsqu'il
s'agit des choses de la raison de
l'esprit il faut être raisonnable pas
très souvent on mélange les deux et il
ne faut pas raisonner dans un esprit de
passion par exemple il y a le sujet de
la passion la souffrance le malheur la
solitude l'affection sujet de passion il
faut être passionné et puis il y a au
contraire les sujets de la raison
l'organisation de la société les
rapports des des uns avec les autres la
façon de faire progresser telle ou telle
institution il faut être raisonnable et
lorsqu'il s'agit de traiter un sujet
raisonnable il faut le traiter de façon
raisonnable donc la passion c'est pour
tout ce qui souffre et pour tout ce qui
vit et la raison c'est pour la solution
des problèmes vous avez toutes les
qualités non je dis pas que j'ai toutes
les qualités mais je dire ce sont deux
choses qu'il faut constamment éprouver
et je pense qu'un chef d'État qu'un
président de la République doit éprouver
les deux parce que il doit avoir le
sentiment de la quantité de
l'accumulation de souffrance et de peine
de son époque à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur j'ai dit par exemple que la
France devait avoir à mes yeux une
politique étrangère libérale dans le
monde c'est-à-dire une politique qui est
pour objet d'alléger la souffrance des
autres ou de respecter mieux les droits
des autres bon bien ça suppose qu'on le
sente ça ne peut pas se faire uniquement
par la raison la raison peut conduire au
contraire des politiques plus réalistes
et bien en même temps je dirais qu'un
président de la République doit être un
homme raisonnable surtout en France
c'est-à-dire dans un pays qui est
toujours vous le savez fragile et sujet
à certains comportements ou à certains
risques comment êtes-vous avec les
autres fi
atin je ne crois pas c'est à vous de me
le dire vous vous interrogez non je ne
crois pas seulement d'abord on a le son
appence physique Mo il se trouve que je
suis grand responsable ou victime de son
physique al on est de sa taille on n'est
pas pour grand-chose je su quelqu' de
plutôt maigre bon ça me donne une
certaine apparence je je suis ainsi mais
dans mes rapports personnels je crois
vraiment que mes rapports personnels
sont très directs j'avais raconté
d'ailleurs dans l'émission de télévision
je parlais de de moi au moment du
premier tour j'ai passé un an et demi de
ma vie comme soldat de seconde classe
dans un régiment venu d'Afrique du Nord
et composé pour l'essentiel de
d'africain du Nord c'est des musulmans
euh d'Algérie qui qui constituaient et
bien j'ai vécu vraiment dans un milieu
qui était un qui milieu actuel si vous
voulez les travailleurs immigrés en
France j'ai eu avec mes camarades avec
mes amis de l'époque les rapports les
plus simples les plus directs et j'en
garde un souvenir avec un souvenir très
fidèle d'ailleurs l'un d'entre eux au
début de la campagne électorale j'avais
jamais revu depuis est venu m'apporter
une photo qu'il avait pris gardé dans
une enveloppe et on nous voyait tous les
deux en 1945 il y a également les
formules je veux regarder la France au
fond des yeux moi je voudrais savoir ce
qu'il y a au fond des yeux de
giscardestin alors les formules n'est-ce
pas il faut voir que c'est utile vous
les préparez les formules elles ne
viennent pas toutes seul non on est
réfléchit on réfléchit à un sujet et
puis tout à coup la formule vient mais
regardez par exemple quelqu'un les
grands hommes d'État comme chchill ou
comme Roosevelt ont toujours cherché des
formules de GA trouver les formules
parce que à un certain moment la formule
illustre et permet à la population à
l'opinion de comprendre quelle est
l'essentiel ou quelle est la direction
qu'on lui propose de choisir il se
trouve que j'ai eu un certain nombre de
formules qui en effet ont été connues
comme par exemple i oui comme par
exemple le 8 mai le 8 mai c'était une
chose très simple c'était l'analyse de
la situation politique du moment et
quand j'ai prononcé ce mot je ne
m'attendais pas du tout à ce qu'il ait
le le succès ou l'écho qu'il a eu par la
suite vous êtes obligé de reconnaître
que vous êtes l'homme d'un milieu
l'homme d'une caste lorsque vous serez
si vous y êtes au sommet de votre
ambition serez-vous capable de dépasser
ce milieu et cette caste et sans vous
renier bon alors d'une caste sûrement
pas c'est pas parce je dis le mot c s
rien de péjtif milieu c'est une origine
en effet d' j'attche pas beaucoup d'IMP
ance et j'espère que dans la France de
demain on s'occupera pas éternellement
de l'origine des uns ou des autres il
n'y a pas de raison d'avoir une espèce
de racisme en réalité politique ou
sociale à cet égard de toute façon je ne
renie jamais ce que je suis vous avez dû
voir que je n'ai jamais pris une
attitude de facilité ou de reniment par
rapport à quoi que ce soit et je ne le
ferai pas mais par contre ça ne
constitue pas du tout pour moi un
obstacle ou une différence d'abord les
choses que je suis ce que je suis devenu
je le dois pas du tout à une origine je
le dois à des concours je dois des
élections bon des élections dans une
circonscription qui est typiquement
populaire dans un département qui une
majorité socialiste pendant des années
donc véritablement ce que je suis dans
la vie politique française vient de ce
que j'ai fait non pas de l'endroit d'où
je viendrai
et je continurai par la suite à avoir
les rapports peut-être les plus directs
et les plus simples avec tous ceux avec
lesquels j' aura l'occasion de
travailler je le sais vous méditez vous
travailler seul et il paraît que lorsque
vous travaillez vous êtes inabordable
consacré et je ne veux même pas employer
d'autres mots
oui très concentré mais ça ça tient si
voulais une méthode de travail c'est
quelqu'un qui essaie d'aller au fond des
choses et qui essaie d'aller
relativement vite au fond des choses
parce que je crois que il faut pas
délayer l'analyse d'une situation
peut-être capable de trancher assez vite
d'autre part quand je fais des discours
je l'ai fait moi-même or vous savez très
bien qu'écrire composer un discours
lorsque vous parlez 1 heure 1 he30 2h
c'est un très gros travail qui prend du
temps alors à ce moment-là en effet je
me concentre je me concentre seul mais
c'est une méthode c'est un choix de
travail vous êtes tolérant et constant
dans votre tolérance j'ai horreur de
l'intolérance horreur d'abord je crois
n'avoir jamais pratiqué l'intolérance et
j'ai horreur de l'intolérance et
lorsqu'il y a dans une société
quelconque la manifestation de
l'intolérance j'ai horreur de cette
intolérance je dirais même que au cours
des dernières années dans certains
mouvements dans certaines tendances de
la jeunesse française qui est une
tendance une jeunesse extraordinairement
vivant et capable c'est pas que nous
allons voir arriver au pouvoir parce que
c'est une des caractéristiques de
l'époque actuelle il y a un trait par
exemple que j'ai regretté je ne
comprends pas qui chez certains d'entre
eux une certaine intolérance vous croyez
à la méchanceté à l'agressivité qui son
fores d'aujourd'hui oui oui vous les
pratiqueer pas du tout non vous pouvez
être très méchant vous pouvez être très
agressé j'ai jamais été très méchant
alors il peut y avoir chezvous une
agressivité rentrée ce qui est encore
pire non je crois vraimentf très
difficile de répondre des questions
pareilles je crois vraiment navoir
aucune forme de méchanceté je ne crois
pas d'agressivité je nen sais rien parce
que tout le monde est vement
peux'emporter naturellement moi aussi
mais la méchanceté c'est-à-dire le désir
de blesser de chercher la partie faible
de faire mal c'est vraiment je crois
quelque chose que je n pas votre
courtoisie c'est une politesse ou c'est
un alibi c'est ni l'un ni l'autre non
c'est le sens de l'existence de des
autres une victoire si vous aviez cette
victoire lundi pourrait être également
considérée comme une défaite vous y avez
pensé moi je réagis suivant les 50 50 je
m'en tiens au dernier
sondage pas j'ai regretté qu'on donne
cette présentation à la campagne
présidentielle elle est donnée oui elle
été donnée je crois que c'est une
mauvaise action c'est une mauvaise
action parce que il faut bien comprendre
de toute façon il y a deux candidats
dans notre système présidentiel et ces
deux candidats l'un aura un peu plus de
50 % l'autre aura un peu moins de 50 %
quel qu'il soit mais c'est la règle du
jeu ça ne coupe pas la France en deux
c'est la modalité de désignation du
président de la République et donc
l'idée que parce que pour choisir un
président de la République il y a deux
candidats ça veut dire que les Français
vont se battre entre eux c'est à mon
avis une très mauvaise président tion
etess rendre un très mauvais service que
de décrire des choses comme celle-là
dans cette affaire les Français ne se
battent pas les uns contre les autres
ils ont à choisir ils ont à choisir
entre deux hommes qui représentent deux
tendances deux conceptions de l'avenir
politique de la France mais un choix ne
comporte pas à mes yeux de victoires ou
de défaite et par exemple pour moi les
les Français qui ne voteront pas pour
moi le 19 mai ne seront pas du tout des
Français donc je me dirai en me
réveillant le 20 mai ces Français ont
été vaincu je me dirais simplement ils
ont fait un autre choix et j'essaierai
d'ailleurs par la suite si je suis élu
de leur faire sentir pourquoi finalement
le choix qui a été fait par la majorité
des Français était le meilleur pour vous
l'important c'est l'ésée c'est le
couronnement de vos
ambitions non non moi ce qui est
important je suis dans une grande
confrontation
nationale dont je mesure l'ampleur et je
dirais c'est très très impressionnant
pour quelqu'un qui n'a pas 50 ans de se
dire que c'est vous jouz beaucoup avec
votre ge non parce qu'il est là vous
savez comme le V n'est pas là il est
toujours là et puis il est là jusqu'à ce
qu'il s'en arrive alors c'est quand même
très important quand on a pas 50 ans de
se dire que l'on représente pour pour
ses compatriotes la possibilité d'un
choix par ce qui a étit très frappant
dans le premier tour de la campagne
présidentielle pour moi c'est que je
n'avais pas d'organisation
pratiquement et donc ceux qui ont voté
pour moi ils ont voté pour m'aider ils
n'ont pas voté pour le parti Intel ou
pour le syndicat Intel ils ont voté pour
m'aider donc il y a 8lions 300000
personnes qui ont vter pour m'aider et
qui d'ailleurs me l'ont dit parce qu'ils
m'ont écrit ils se sont manifestés comme
comme cela dans la campagne alors ce qui
est important si vous voulez pour moi
c'est pas l'Élysée n'est-ce pas c'est
pas d'imaginer que la semaine prochaine
je franchirai le le Porsche oval de
l'Élysée ce n'est pas ça c'est de
représenter un certain choix pour la
France vous faites des promesses
démagogiques ce que vous promettez
pourquoi ne l'avez-vous pas accordé
plutôt d'abord nous sont pas démagogique
je fais ENF entre guillemet si vous
voulez très bien mettez les guillemet je
promets j'ouvre un certain nombre de
perspectives parce qu'il y aura un
avenir mais votre question est très
intéressante parce que là-dessus il y a
une volonté d'égarer les Français on dit
comment se fait-il que quelqu'un propose
quelque chose pour l'avenir qu'il n'a
pas fait dans le passé mais c'est
toujours le cas car il y a toujours
quelque chose d'autre à faire supposez
que soit monsieur vééran soit moi-même
soyons président de la République et
bien à la fin de notre mandat il y aura
encore d'autres choses à faire nous ne
dirons pas le monde s'arrête parce que
notre mandat s'arrête alors en 196 74 il
y a des choses à décider pour l'avenir
et de même qu'au cours des dernières
années nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses la France a fait beaucoup de
choses et je regrette que dans cette
campagne présidentielle on cherche à lui
faire croire qu'elle n'a rien fait parce
que vous circulez dans le monde moi je
je l'ai fait aussi et vous savez très
bien tout le monde considère que la
France est un pays qui a énormément
progressé et on dit mais en effet ce qui
s'est passé en France c'est très
remarquable alors l'idée que la France
est resté les bras croisés depuis 10 ans
c'est une idée qui est injuste pour la
réalité française mais il y a toujours
d'autres chose à faire si vous étiez
président de la République et s l'an
était d'accord prendriez-vous Monsieur
François mitero comme premier ministre
euh question importante oui c'est une
question importante éce il y a un choix
clair à faire c'est un choix entre deux
organisations économiques et sociales
qui sont très différentes celle que je
propose d'une part celle que propose
monsieur mitéran et elles sont très
différentes or pour moi la règle dans la
politique c'est la clarté et puisque les
Françis les Français choisiront un
certain type d'organisation il faut que
les hommes qui conduisent la politique a
dans l'esprit ce type d'organisation
donc compte tenu du choix de Monsieur
François mitéran à l'heure actuelle je
vous réponds non par contre il se trouve
que dans le ce qu'était le parti de
Monsieur mitteran lorsqu'il est jusqu à
la 5e République c'est-à-dire l'UDSR il
y a beaucoup d'hommes la plupart d'entre
eux qui ont opté en ma faveur alors si
monsieur miteran était resté en somme
dans ce parti c'est quelqu'un qui aurait
eu vocation à participer au respons pour
l'avenir vous pourriez dire non mais
pour un socialiste je voudrais vous
poser une dernière question vous
connaissez cette phrase de Michelet le
difficile n'est pas monter mais en
montant de rester soi non ce n'est pas
difficile de rester soi et je veux dire
ce n'est pas pour moi le problème
j'espère reste-moi j'espère me
perfectionner un peu mais j'espère
rester moi non le difficile en réalité
c'est de rester avec les autres comme
les autres ce n'est pas d'être soi-même
c'est d'être aussi possible aussi
semblable que possible aux autres c'est
d'être comme les
autres